for the second night in a row clashes
commotion and angry protests turned into
an outburst of fury in Barcelona's city
centre police say some forty thousand
protesters had made their way here some
even prepared for violence as they threw
bottles and set fire to rubbish
containers what began as a peaceful
vigil
soon after turned into a riot zone with
the two main thoroughfares in the city
centre quickly turned into a no-go area
[Music]
regional leaders so often at odds with
the central government in Madrid have
been calling for a campaign of civil
disobedience protester benign Catalan
politicians and activists convicted of
sedition on Monday the goal they say
safeguarding Catalonia's right to
self-determination this is what now is
the key thing and to defend to be the
government of Catalonia in the front of
the defense of the rights that now after
the sentences have been limited or
prohibited this latest wave of protests
organized by a leaderless movement known
as a democratic tsunami is prepared to
take a more hardline approach but not
everyone agrees with a strategy some
Catalan nationalists have condemned the
violent tactics and the central
government in Madrid promised a fully
investigate who was behind the latest
wave of disruption but this is a week
where activists have promised to keep on
protesting since the secession attempt
two years ago both Pro and anti
independence stances have hardened
neither side is prepared to give way to
dialogue just yet
Sonia Gallegos al Jazeera Barcelona